welcome back to new rockstars it's one
of mission week and did kevin feige just
tell us that this series could
ramp into the x-men's arrival to the mcu
well on the eve of marvel's next phase i
put together some of my favorite nerds
to try to figure out
how wandavision could introduce the
house of mama
mutants i am eric voss this is rogue
theory going rogue with me today
is tommy beck told hey eric how are you
i'm doing good buddy uh partially
because
of everyone who's here including our
favorite
sometimes scarlet witch cosplayer all
other times amazing twitch
personality and just amazing person
angelica trey
hi it's good to be back and yes i'll do
some more cosplays soon especially as
one division's going on
it's it's your time to shine i believe
in you and we are thrilled to welcome
two new rock stars co-host of
the film lucifer's podcast eddie
villanueva hey buddy
how's it going man how's it going good
to be here we are so happy to have you
here
uh this lineup boy oh boy we're gonna
figure it out i believe in us this is
this is a good time to be alive
uh because in various interviews for one
division marvel head kevin feige
has been dropping hints about his plans
for the x-men in the mcu
and when asked specifically if one
division was a ramp to the revival of
the x-men that he has been planning for
years
he said quote well everything can be a
ramp to everything
with a mental wink that i inferred via
telepathy
and uh when he asked when we would see
the x-men
in another interview he said i can't
tell you everything before we actually
introduce it but rest assured the
discussions have been
long and ongoing internally hmm
sounds like two big yeses to me
folks let's figure it out right here
right now
team like last week no more my scripted
pitch versus your scripted pitch
but like the avengers we will join
forces and win or lose we'll do it
together
how will wanda vision introduce the
mutants to the mcu
because we are assuming it will and i
want to lead this
conversation with this whole theory that
the house of m
events will tie into it uh how likely do
you think it is that at some point
during one division
uh wanda while having similar house of
psionic meltdowns might uh just whisper
some kind of incantation
and then poof uh mutants will
suddenly exist in the universe kind of a
different uh reversal
uh from house of m where she erased them
i was gonna say i kind of feel like
that's what this series is gonna build
towards i feel like we're gonna get a
lot of that
build up towards that one point that's
going to be similar to how we got with
uh avengers
infinity war uh avengers infinity war
where everybody knew that that snap was
gonna happen it was inevitable
uh no pun intended but it was going to
happen it was pretty much
everybody was calling it from a long
shot and then when it came to that point
where the snap happened and
everything that we had had wanted to see
slash not wanted to see happen
happened i think that's going to be the
similar vein with this one i think we're
going to lead
towards that point of house of m where
she does
say something to the effect of no more
mutants but on that
momentous scale and create this
alternate reality of people who are
different
uh so i could totally see that too and i
think we've touched on this
before you know in the one division
trailer
she has the twins in one of those scenes
too
and those are probably going to be uh
wiccan and speed right yeah we think so
yeah so like she could probably just
will them maybe into
existence uh clearly she's having a
mental break and there could be
some overlap here where the the
worlds bleed over i think the question
will be is it going to be an
alternate universe at first that the
mutants exist in like she'll create a
house of m
universe and we'll see like a reality if
a lot of people were superpowered or
are they going to spawn within the prime
mcu universe that we know like
she's going to open up the multiverse
and basically all the mutants are just
going to spill out
kind of situation i think it's possible
that one division could end by kind of
making that new reality where the house
of m mutants all exist happily
but that kind of just sets up the
multiverse saga
and then at some uh future installment
maybe multiverse of madness or something
like that all of that could get
collapsed back together
so that way now we all have mutants
alongside avengers and guardians of the
galaxy and all that
other stuff uh tommy which of these do
you think would be
more confusing for the average marvel
fan i'm already very confused as
as usual i think that the the way that
you have to do this
uh is the way that you have to always do
these movies which is a little bit of
spoon feeding
which is why i think the approach is
going to be uh
simply some sort of cosmic event that
awakens the mutant gene in people you
know what i mean like i think that
uh rather than they're being like let's
introduce a bunch of convoluted ways for
these people to
come into the universe they're gonna
have already been there just kind of
dormant like dinosaur eggs
stuck in time frozen in the tundras of
canada
only to be awoken by an incubator and
bringing forth
the majesty of dinosaurs see what i've
said is confusing
now because i'm confused i lash out with
the emotion that i feel
so yeah i think that really i have a
feeling it's going to be similar to a
snap
it's going to be a one moment that just
kind of awakens all these familiar
mutants that we know and love from the
comics
the theory direction you're going in is
that um
that mutants could get introduced in one
division but that won't be the chief
reveal at the end of this series or at
the end of this season
uh if it's a multiverse and if that's
the direction they're gonna go
multiverse is the answer basically to
a lot of questions we have but if it's
just mutants have always been there as
the explanation and that may be
a past snap release radiation that
activated all their mutant genes
then maybe that's just a little thing
that's planted in a flashback in like
episode four or five or six
and then we readdress that in a later
installment and that wanda and vision
story is just their own
thing in the end game of this of this
series i i think a lot of people go back
and forth on what's the more exciting
way to introduce them right
do uh you say that they've been there
the whole time i think a lot of people
are uh bummed out at that idea of like
well have we missed them why haven't
they helped
but if it's just like a lot of people
had these powers or
maybe they died early but the the snap
kind of recoded
their dna so that now they're able to
walk the earth with like
the ability to move super fast or make
things really cold
or manipulate fire
or you know read people's minds whatever
it is could you imagine how catastrophic
that would be though if it was like that
that leftover radiation
from a snap and then all of a sudden all
of the mutant genes are unlocked and now
you've got mutants running around
i feel like there'd be people like
speeding into things people like blowing
stuff
up it would be so much havoc but it'd be
a lot of fun
and that's i think a good uh explanation
why that might not be the case because
we saw spider-man far from home
happen a couple months after in game or
several months after end game
and uh there was no talk of uh of people
with like
sudden superpowers around the world
so i don't know how um connected to the
snap it will be
other than maybe it there's like a six
month delay or something
like the radiation and maybe new
children or something like that
or the snap ruptured some other
alternate universe but then we're going
back to multiverse is the answer right
it leans more to the fact of how much
weight they're going to be putting on
that idea of the multiverse as we move
into this new phase
how much of an importance that's going
to play moving forward
um because to be quite honest we've only
seen glimpses of it whether if it's from
ant-man or from
you know avengers end game we've only
seen glimpses of what the multiverse
could look like even with doctor strange
and now kind of moving forward into this
new arena where we're going to be
talking about things where we haven't
really
fully touched on in the mcu thus far the
multiverse
as kind of the on the nose answer as it
is
does seem like the most plausible yeah
from the beginning we we have to kind of
rewind the clock and look at what was
feige's original plan for this because
you know uh
one division was not going to be the
first title of uh mcu phase four
uh black widow was and then we were
gonna have a falcon winner soldier and
then
probably gonna have eternals after that
and then maybe one division
so it's gonna be like the fourth title
uh however it was always in
the works to have wanda maximoff return
for multiverse of madness
that's why i think this series could end
by kind of punting
on the mutant question but that question
and the multiverse will be
very much a big part of doctor strange
2 and spider-man 3 it looks like with
doctor strange appearing in it
um but to me the most exciting version
of this
is that some mutants have existed but
it's just been on
a smaller scale like imagine imagine
this explanation
and maybe we'll get an answer like this
in eternals that
mankind has not needed um
superpowers but the arrival of
superpowered individuals in the 20th
century has
triggered some kind of genetic mutation
in the human race that has been there
since uh you know millennia before
when the deviants and the eternals were
running around uh but that
now that like captain america has
arrived that like people like
hulk and thor her walking around on a
midgard uh
mankind has developed a response to that
and
all of that has been tied in and now we
need
mutants in the world to match that
strength and survival of the fittest
and darwinianism is kicking in and
that's a really good intro
into a lot of of topics and themes that
are
in the x-men movies right where it's
like
the argument that it's evolution and
that you know some of the mutants
you know feel like they're superior and
i could definitely see that argument now
getting woven
into the mcu that's really cool and is
it possible
i think i think what i really really
sorry i think what i absolutely really
really want to see
at the end of all this i want to see
this like wormhole
come out of the middle of nowhere with
vision standing in the middle of nowhere
and out comes reed richards
and he's been trying to connect
universes from one side to the next and
it's john krasinski that's all i'm
saying that's all i want to say i think
that's all a lot of us want to see
tommy you were about to say something oh
i i think it doesn't really connect
at this point it's fine it's all good
[Laughter]
you have a skill i wish i had in
conversations and being able to let go
of a thread for me i'm always like hey i
know the conversation moved on from this
three minutes ago
but can we circle back to this point i
need to make oh yeah
i'll share a pun from like a
conversation we had 10 minutes ago i'm
like okay i waited
now i'm gonna drop this pun holding onto
it
yeah so it's interesting obviously
multiverse
is being set up in in one division uh
but for multiverse to be the answer for
mutants that's kind of answering a
question with a question
right so i feel like one division could
introduce mutants but i don't know if
multiverse is going to be the answer i
don't know if house of m
i think there's going to be some
parallel south of them in the show but i
don't think they're going to go all the
way with it
i think house of m we might see uh
pieces of it in multiverse of madness
especially if wanda maxwell is a villain
because in house of m wanda maximoff is
kind of the antagonist in that
however i think uh they will address the
mutant question
in a historical perspective by flashing
back to sokovia and i think the only
reason they're doing that is because
marvel acknowledges that age of ultron
had its hands tied behind its back and
the way they could talk about
pietro and wanda they couldn't call them
mutants when you know marvel fans know
that they're mutants in comics
and now we might see a bit of that
history and how they had a natural
genetic predisposition
aka an x gene but one thing i want to
ask all three of you about paul bettany
said in an interview
that there is a mystery actor uh someone
he has always always always wanted to
work with that's going to be surprised
to everyone
and that this person and him have
fireworks in the show
you know i've speculated this could be
just based off of who
petney has worked with before maybe
richard e grant who's uh confirmed for
loki and i think
will be on a big bad and in the mcu
going forward
maybe doctor doom that guy's so good he
could do a lot of different things
but do you guys think this could be a
past x-men actor
that they're going to fold into this
universe i was actually just thinking
that when you mentioned that i was like
it'd be so great for him to meet you
know uh sir patrick stewart
in that instance just have that that one
interaction between the two of them even
if it's just mentally
you know have them come together in this
kind of spatial area even within maybe
the multiverse
itself that's perfect for professor x
too yeah that would be amazing
i would love that i love sir patrick
stewart and just him as professor
x also he's my captain so yeah he's all
of our captains
um yeah that would be awesome i i mean
obviously
i'm still pretty sore after after the
events of logan i won't bring him up
but um it would be really great to see
sir patrick stewart again
does anyone have any insight on where
you think this will come in
timeline wise because you know i
wouldn't mind seeing like phoenix um
like or jean grey
you know type situation coming in but i
don't know where that timeline would be
yeah i mean i would say we don't even
have to worry about timeline anymore
if they're gonna kind of reboot the
events of the fox x-men things
i i wouldn't imagine jack schaefer the
one division team or feige
really held themselves that hard to
whatever the brian singer
and uh simon kinberg were working on
over at fox so they could just de-age
sir patrick stewart
and sure you know just like they've done
it before
one more time yeah i i wouldn't mind
just because i don't want to see
all those fox x-men actors just go to
waste i think uh mcavoy fassbender
so so talented if they were to just
bring in fast bender to be the mcu
magneto
i would be here for it i think we're
missing the obvious answer here guys
and that is veto
kelsey grammer as beast it's gotta be
it's gotta be frasier we all are
ignoring the elephant in the room that
paul bettany is a huge cheers fan
and uh has spoken on record about how
much
he loves the cast of cheers and where is
the link there
uh to me it's kelsey grammer and if it's
not him then it's giancarlo esposito who
was not in cheers but is a great actor
oh
he wasn't talks or ted danson as reed
richards there you go
yeah giancarlo esposito would be great
keanu reeves uh who's always been to
talks to join the mcu if this is who
they're talking about like a big name
like that
i mean yeah he's gonna be johnny though
he he's only ever john or johnny
up some john johnny names within x-men
within that universe and throw it in
yeah throw it in the comments or
something i don't know yeah
let's see but keanu can only play john
johnny's
nothing else yeah absolutely um well uh
we do want to hear from you in the
comments
um just to wrap this conversation up
because you know
we'll have to be watching one division
tonight but because
i have this kind of brain i still
mentally award points to each of you
i know i said that we weren't competing
but everyone's in competition in my
brain
so let's see i am going to
give tommy one point for kelsey grammer
uh i think that we gotta see him again
uh i'm gonna give eddie two points for
sir patrick stewart
showing up uh he needs to just get at
least a cameo in the mcu and i think
every actor
said i to share uh a scene with patrick
stewart please
in my career and then angelica i'm going
to give you three points
uh for your general theories for
uh how one division is going to go and
um your
mix of uh skepticism but imaginative
wishful thinking for where this series
could go if i'm anything
it's it's skepticism but also wishful
thinking balance balance
thank you there you go all right so
we're gonna keep talking about one
division this
episode because there's too much to talk
about and obviously you can see if
you've been watching rogue theory we are
trying a new format where we just kind
of all talk about it as if you know
we're sharing a room together in a
podcast
as opposed to like you know being
isolated and just reading off a computer
screen something we wrote ahead of time
hopefully it feels more organic i love
it more i feel like we're able to go to
more interesting depths and make more of
a conversation
let us know what you think about this
new format we didn't tweak it that much
but uh find me on twitter at eavos it's
really the best way to reach me
but you can also find us on our discord
server open to all channel patrons
patreon.com
new rockstars also we want to announce
some stuff new rockstars and our merch
partners at epic hero shop have
two really amazing wanda vision inspired
t-shirt designs at new
rockstarsmerch.com
each shirt has an augmented reality
element
built into it and if you purchase the
latest obsession shirt
you have the option to get an on-screen
shout out in our inside marvel after
show
uh also epic hero shop has a companion
shirt to it
you don't want to split up the unusual
couple you want to keep this couple
together
so be sure to check out epic hero shop's
uh wanda shirt
it also has an ar component uh i didn't
know that
shirts could do this it's so crazy it's
kind of like watching uh one division
it's like i didn't know
marvel things could do this um also and
this is something we've never done
before
our friends at epic hero shop are giving
away 10
ps5s playstation 5s you enter by
subscribing to their youtube channel
it's called epic hero labs
it's a very interesting channel that has
like hidden messages in it
i don't know what's going on there maybe
you can tell me um and then
you can fill out the form that you find
at epicuroshop.com
giveaway every 10 000 subscribers there
will be a new winner announced of a ps5
there's also a bunch of ways to get in
more entries into that giveaway at that
website so go check that out
epiccaroshop.com giveaway
so we want to move on to talk about
vision and whether or not he has a
future in the mcu after this but
first we want to thank our friends at
bespoke post for sponsoring this episode
so the curators at bespoke post have
done it again this winter folks
with an all new lineup of a central box
of awesome collections for guys
guaranteed
to upgrade your life i have gotten some
great
kitchen items at bespoke post in the
past that have come in handy since i
have been cooking at home more lately
uh whether it's cool equipment to up
your cooking game or cozy threads to
survive the chilly days
bespoke post only sends guys the best
stuff every month no matter what you're
into
box of awesome has you covered style
grooming goods bar wear outdoor gear
box of awesome has collections for every
part of your life
for folks looking to go alcohol free in
the new year doing your dry annuals
their new dry box has all of the
ingredients to make a really tasty
mocktail old old-fashioned so it feels
like you're getting it
but you're staying true to your new
year's resolutions good for you
take the quiz at box of awesome.com your
answers will help them pick the right
box of awesome for you
and they release new boxes every month
across a ton of different categories
it's free to sign up and you can skip a
month or cancel any time each box only
costs 45 bucks but it has over 70
dollars worth of gear inside
so here's what you do you get 20 off
your first monthly box when you sign up
at box of awesome.com
and enter the code rogue at checkout
that's box of awesome.com
code rogue for 20 off your first box
this episode is also sponsored by
bluechu
guys do you remember the days when
you're always ready to go
now you can get back that extra
confidence in bed from our friends at
bluechew.com that's
blue like the color blue b-l-u-e blue
chew
brings you the first chewable with the
same fda approved active ingredients as
viagra and cialis you can take them any
time day or night so you can be ready
whenever an opportunity arises
blue chew is prescribed online by
licensed physicians so you don't have to
go to the doctor's office and wait line
at the pharmacy
and it ships directly to your door in a
discreet
package unless you are tommy bech told
and you want the world to know via
confetti cannons
that's this isn't for you i always say
eric if you can't swallow a pill like an
adult you should be able to chew your ed
medicine like a flintstone vitamin
uh yeah
they are so blue chews are made in the
usa
and since bluetooth repairs and ships
direct they're cheaper than a pharmacy
there's no awkwardness no leaving the
house
right now we've got a special deal for
our listeners visit bluechew.com and get
your first shipment free
when you use our special promo code of
rogue just pay five dollars in shipping
again that's b-l-u-e
chew.com promo code rogue to try it free
blue chew is a better cheaper choice
folks and remember when you support our
sponsors you help make this show
possible so
please be sure to use our promo code
rogue bluetooth.com
and this episode was sponsored by me
undies me undies has teamed up with
marvel to launch their brand new super
soft avengers collection
uh the avengers are not super soft the
avengers are hard as hell
but the me undies are so so soft so you
feel like you're
supported and nuzzled down there you can
be
cosplaying as your favorite marvel
superhero under your clothes
me undies are made from micro modal
fabric which is
not only soft but breathable and light
impossibly cozy
i have a pair of me undies lounge pants
and they are
insanely comfortable so basically if
pajama bottoms had a baby with a cloud
their offspring would feel like me on
these lounge pants i wear them around
the house
and they take my lounge abilities up
several notches and you guys know me i
love to lounge
i love to lounge lounge lounge lounge
their new limited edition avengers print
features some of your favorite
superheroes captain america
black panther thor hulk iron man black
widow more
check out the new collection in undies
socks loungewear
buddy bands for your pet your pet can
have a bandana on that matches your
underwear
i gotta get one of these for darla she
she would be like yes i love you and
i'll never bark at night time ever again
we'll see me undies has their problem
free philosophy
so if you're not satisfied with any
product for any reason they'll refund or
exchange it no caveats no questions
isn't that great
to get your 15 off your first order and
free shipping
go to meundies.com rockstars that's
meundies.com
rockstars all right the second half of
our titular duo of wanda vision
is in a unique place mr vision we
watched him
die in infinity war and not come back
and end game so
you know we kind of assume he's still
dead despite appearing in the nine
episodes of this disney plus series
but that you know the mysteries of the
show are all tied and how he comes back
is it a projection from wanda's mind
are we seeing flickering channels in the
multiverse where he's still alive is it
some kind of
demonic trickery we'll find out through
watching the show how vision is alive
and whether he will stay alive but i
want to know from you guys what do you
think uh visions post one division
future is going to be
is he going to survive after the series
is he going to
evolve into a new form have we seen the
final form of vision
i recall like discussing this with you
before
eric but i feel like it might be
a bit of a cop-out i don't want to say
this necessarily but
we've talked about her wanda possibly
absorbing
like some of visions like soul
or something and then just bringing him
back
to the mcu um that might be a bit of a
cop out
so i'm not sure if that's going to
happen but i could see him transforming
into like a different i don't know like
them bringing him back in
some other form i don't know what do you
guys think i think i think there's a big
possibility here of us seeing
shuri finish what she was trying to do
at the end of
uh infinity war where she was trying to
remove the mind stone from vision
and quite possibly in the same instance
this is kind of where
maybe the the the storyline starts to
meld where
while you know maybe there's some
instance where wanda's kind of in
inside whatever's left of of vision and
this is what they're both creating with
her power and her ability i love that
idea
you're saying wanda's right from the
outside and yeah and wanda from the
inside
oh okay that's a very interesting idea
uh this is all like and i love
when um you know you go inside someone's
mind and it's just kind of their mind
palace so
all kinds of fantasy crap is looking
possible but really it's just like
what we're seeing our enclosed
references yeah that's right uh neutrons
are being tied together
uh and juan is trying it's like um uh
corbin dallas multipass
in the fifth element uh or ultron i
guess we should say is a more apt to
reference here
uh where it's just like watching a bunch
of tv from the 20th century to try to
figure out what humanity is
i'm interested in wondering or or
finding out like what
what does it mean to be vision in
another multiverse you know what i mean
like in another
like another universe like what is it
like vision came about
in this universe because as an answer to
defeat ultron right like he was a
solution to the problem so in what
scenarios
was vision created in these other
dimensions and so and is there
an answer in there in how to bring this
vision back is there
is it uh is he always a like uh being
formed with like a combination of ai
and organic materials is he just an
organic being in other universes with
the soul of vision quote unquote
or or or what or how does that happen
and i think that
if they go lean heavier into the
multiverse in this show
uh instead of just in the in the doctor
strange movie we could see
maybe the answer to this vision coming
back uh
as influenced by another version of
vision a vision version
an alternate version vision a virgin
version vision alternate vision version
visage tongue twisters from school
yeah season two is just gonna be called
vision vision or
vision wanda so so wanda's just
opening up the multiverse and everyone's
spilling out
basically right tommy okay yeah i mean
i'm saying
if they go that way i would prefer
eddie's plan to be honest with you i
like eddie's idea
that would be my preferred way that it
happens but if they are going to use
this as a
introduction to all of these characters
perhaps
somewhere in these dimensional riffs
lies the answer to how to bring this
vision back or
why this vision is back oh just to say
we can't be done with paul benton
that's all i have to say we can't be
done with that i agree can we
uh do that thing where i don't know how
to have conversation so i loop back to a
point i want to make earlier and
say i just want uh something to be
called a vish called wanda
let's be honest there's there's a decent
scenario where paul bettany returns to
the mcu as jarvis right like there's
definitely a pathway where like vision
dies
in this show and then all of a sudden in
one of the new
uh mcu movies the technology to jarvis
or the original drive of jarvis's
personality or whatever is
found in stark's industries stock
industry somewhere
and someone else in the mcu uses jarvis
or you know
utilizes jarvis that's what i want
honestly
everyone knows my feelings about vision
he's just too much of a frankenstein
character for me to attach with them i'm
hoping one division changes that
um but i think uh paul bettany was so
much more interesting as jarvis than he
was his vision
and i'm sure paul bettany if the pay is
the same which it isn't because it will
be voiceover versus
you know being on camera but like i
i'm sure that guy uh has loved being on
camera and won division because he
doesn't have to be a makeup all the time
but
uh if i hope that jarvis can exist going
forward in the future i love jarvis and
i miss him
i miss jarvis so here's what i'm gonna
do uh tommy i'm giving you one point for
the jarvis theory
eddie i'm giving you two points though
for your uh theory i think that is
fascinating and i hope that's what one
division is
why not why not both why not have him as
jarvis and then bring him back in like a
different form like white vision or
something too
absolutely he could get double paychecks
yeah double vision
double vision i think the answer to all
of new rockstars uh rogue theory
episodes is all of these theories will
be right
eventually we just might not live to see
it happen yeah at some point
oh god all right um let's move oh
damn it the road question is heroical
question is
what is the surprise actor that paul
betty was referring to
so here's what i'm going to do on the
fly i'm going to use my improv skills
to improvise one i haven't done this in
a while
sweet i heard uh acoustic guitar
oh i just happen to have one oh i just
have to
sidechat i saw an improv show at an
improv festival one time
where they were like we can do any genre
of music
in the world just shout out a genre of
music and wayne brady it and
people were like saying real hard stuff
like reggae and
uh bluegrass and then ever like there
was probably six or seven different ones
and the guy goes
i think i heard acoustic guitar and we
looked around there's like
20 of us in the audience they're like no
let's say that we're all supervisors
and we're also like acoustic guitar is
not a genre of music it's an instrument
i just kept saying that that's beautiful
i love that
everybody knows mine right next to me
acoustic guitar is not a genre it's a
personality trait
i'm getting college flashbacks again
anyways here's wonderwall yes oh come on
angelica you're unbelievable though
you're a great musician i'm talking
i'm talking a guy at a college party
that takes something
smoke on the water hey hey hey i'll
start playing like wish you were here
randomly and everyone just like plays
that riff and i'll be like
yeah i know how to play guitar
like that's that's me yeah i can be that
person
no i just choose not to all the time but
it's a great song it's a great song
yeah you are a good person um all right
so here's going to be our road question
to decide it all
paul bettany in an interview last month
um
answered a question that no one really
had asked
and what color is vision's private parts
and how do they work
and he said quote it's purple so now
that
uh paul bettany has made this mcu cannon
uh
how detachable are visions privates
are visions his vision sentience
contained in his privates
and would he have to have a standoff
battle uh
the way he did with ultron with his
privates
with his purple android
okay so there's a song uh by king
missile
that i am thinking of that's going to
age me for detachable penis yes
i think that could have been inspired by
by this conversation i like to think
that as like everything with vision is
basically whatever
he wants it to be like that's kind of
the frustrating thing with this
character in my mind is like he can just
kind of do whatever he wants so
i imagine that like whatever it came
standard issue he made bigger
and like more supple like more
intimidating and it's probably more like
a fist than anything else and
you know those the gi joe toy
yeah a nice supple engorged penis you
know we all describe it that way don't
act like that's not normal
hey you know but you know the g.i joe
jeep thing that launched rockets like
it's like
you had like three spring-loaded rockets
i imagine that vision
from like the cro like waist down as a
gi joe jeep
with three three of them a hydra if you
will
uh uh each one more powerful than the
last but dependent upon each other that
can
spring load out in different directions
uh
to the pleasure or devastation of his uh
friends and enemies vision's more of an
efficient person
it's probably looking something more
i don't know i'm just i when i think
vision i think efficient and robotic
with what tommy was saying i'm also
getting visions from like uh
what was that movie with guillermo del
toro who uh
oh with the drawing of mike the fish guy
with the fish shape of water
shape of water there shape of water
where she does that whole like
kind of thing i'm like i'm just i'm
getting a lot of like
those kind of vibes here so exactly
there you go you got it eric you got
it i think it's retractable i think he's
got an innie
and an audi and it yeah it'll
like a switchblade so i think ergonomic
mm-hmm
exactly so he can choose whether you
know
it's like the other side of the
detachable penis it's more of the
retractable the retractable penis yeah
which is going to be king missiles next
oh they're due for a comeback years
later what if it's like a murphy bed
like it just folds up into like a
cumberbund and it looks like it's
functional that it just flops down
i'm doing all this work
see i i'm going off of what eddie said
and i thought you said
it's more efficient being like is more
efficient than he is
so his like the t1000 and vision is the
t800
and then he replaces him and he becomes
a new avenger
uh and that's this is rated r x
17 right yeah yeah yeah yeah
totally my i'm just trying to find ways
to make vision interesting to me
okay that's right so you're saying
vision's
unit is is now its own entity
it's weaponized carbon neutral right
is that okay i think vision would
recognize
the the genetics theory that really uh
all of humanity is are just flesh
puppets in order for our genes to
replicate themselves
and going with that he would understand
that his final form is merely
his anatomical
sexual organs or i got it i got three
words for you
oh three words for you nuclear powered
oh that's you down with three words
wow that's alluring that is alluring um
or it's got an x gene and during the
just returning back to the thanos snap
radiation
was it mutant gene unlock yes basically
it just comes to life one day
it's it's
yeah exactly um i blame myself for
dragging all of us into the gutter here
um so no one's gonna definitely having
some visions about this
none of us should be proud of ourselves
chiefly me
uh but i believe eddie that makes you
the winner of this episode of rogue
theory well done
nice congratulations thank you thank you
npp
so uh that is it for this episode of
rogue theory
uh i want to thank our guests tommy
bechtold angelica trey eddie villanueva
uh be sure to follow all of them on all
their social media channels
uh you can support our channel by
checking out one of our many great merch
options at newrockstarsmerge.com
follow me at eavos follow new rockstar
subscribe here on youtube
be sure to tune in for inside marvel
tomorrow and our breakdowns of the
episodes will come out the following
days
thank you everybody bye
[Music]
you